This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you can recognize any piece of classical music, I bet it's this one. This is Fure Elise, written by Ludwig Van Beethoven in 1810. Maybe it reminds you of piano lessons you took when you were a kid. In my town, it was also the song the ice cream truck used to play. That's producer Avery Trufflement. In my town, it was also the song the ice cream truck used to play. That's producer Avery Troubleman. But if you live in Taiwan, and you hear a truck rumbling down the street playing Fear
这里是99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。如果你能认出任何一首古典音乐，我敢说就是这一首。这是贝多芬于1810年创作的《致爱丽丝》。也许它会让你想起小时候上的钢琴课。在我所在的城镇，这也是冰淇淋车常放的曲子。那是制作人埃弗里·特鲁布尔曼。在我所在的城镇，这也是冰淇淋车常放的曲子。那是制作人埃弗里·特鲁布尔曼。但如果你住在台湾，听到一辆卡车轰鸣着驶过街道，播放着《致
Elise, it doesn't mean it's time to buy a popsicle. It means it's time to take out your trash, because this is what a garbage truck in Taiwan sounds like. This garbage truck song isn't just supposed to be cute and fun, although it is also supposed to be cute and fun. The singing garbage trucks are all a part of a completely different way of thinking about waste disposal, completely different that is from the way that we think about it in the United States. In the late 1990s Taiwan recycled only 5% of its waste.
爱丽丝》，那并不意味着该去买冰棒了。这意味着你该倒垃圾了，因为这就是台湾垃圾车的声音。这首垃圾车之歌不仅仅是为了可爱和有趣，尽管它确实也很可爱和有趣。这些会唱歌的垃圾车完全颠覆了我们对垃圾处理的思考方式，与我们在美国思考的方式截然不同。在20世纪90年代末，台湾只回收了5%的垃圾。
Today Taiwan recycles well over half. The country is now among the world's top recyclers. And what changed in this period has a lot to do with the way that the trash is collected. OK, fur Elise isn't the only song the trucks play. In Taipei, the capital of Taiwan, the trucks also play this song. That's Amadens Prayer, my Polish composer, Tecla Batuzuska, Baronolska. And in Taipei City, the garbage trucks just
如今，台湾的垃圾回收率远超一半。该国目前跻身全球顶级回收国之列。而这一时期发生的变化，在很大程度上与垃圾收集的方式有关。好吧，《致爱丽丝》并不是垃圾车播放的唯一歌曲。在台湾首都台北，垃圾车还会播放这首曲子。那是波兰作曲家泰克拉·巴杜热夫斯卡-巴罗诺夫斯卡的《少女的祈祷》。而在台北市，垃圾车只是
alternate between these two songs. The tech turns to play these two songs, two music, the in Taipei City. Even the elementary school kids can't sing the song. So we have brainwashed. This is Dr. Jasmine Wan, and she grew up in Taipei. Since I was a child, I knew that every time when the garbage truck comes, we were here, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. Now the singing garbage trucks are such a part of life, it's hard to imagine a time before
在这两首歌之间交替播放。这两首歌，在台北市。甚至连小学生的会唱这首歌。所以我们已经被洗脑了。这是黄博士，她在台北长大。从我记事起，我就知道每当垃圾车来的时候，我们都会……现在，唱歌的垃圾车已经成了生活的一部分，很难想象没有
them, but that time actually wasn't too long ago. We used to have a lot of big dumpsters, so there were a lot of rats, mosquitoes and things like that, and it's not good for our health. Just a couple of decades ago, Taipei residents threw their trash into massive smelly dumpsters on the streets. Garbage would end up in piles on the sidewalk and in parks, it would fester in the heat.
它们的时期，但那段时期其实并没有很久以前。我们过去有很多大型垃圾箱，所以有很多老鼠、蚊子之类的东西，这对我们的健康很不好。就在几十年前，台北居民把垃圾扔进街上巨大而恶臭的垃圾箱里。垃圾最终堆积在人行道和公园里，在炎热的天气里腐烂。
It was just nasty. Then Taiwan's democratization accelerated in the mid-1980s and created this desire to tidy up. Being a modern country means being a clean country. And when you have foreign visitors coming and visiting your capital, they shouldn't think, oh, this place is dirty. This is Mary Alice Hadad,
那真是太糟糕了。然后在20世纪80年代中期，台湾的民主化进程加速，并催生了把城市清理干净的愿望。作为一个现代国家意味着成为一个干净的国家。当有外国游客来参观你的首都时，他们不应该认为，哦，这个地方很脏。这是玛丽·爱丽丝·哈达德，
chair of East Asian Studies at Wesleyan University. In Taiwan, the pro-democracy movement got fully entangled with the environmental movement. and so as all those things moved together in the late 80s, early 90s, then the pro-democracy and pro-environment agendas got onto the public consciousness. Also, the environmental movement had a practical end. Taiwan was running out of space to actually put piles of trash because it's a small island and extremely populous small island. There's not that much space where you're going to stick all your junk, whereas in the
卫斯理大学东亚研究系主任。在台湾，民主运动与环保运动完全交织在了一起。因此，随着所有这些事情在80年代末、90年代初共同发展，民主和环保的议程进入了公众意识。此外，环保运动还有一个实际目的。台湾的实际垃圾堆积空间正在耗尽，因为它是一个小岛，而且是一个人口极其密集的小岛。没有那么多空间让你堆放所有垃圾，而在
United States there has been historically a sense of the untamed, untabbed, endless wilderness. And you could just throw your junk into the wilderness and it would go away and you wouldn't have to worry about anymore. Not true in Taipei. It's a big city but it's really clean and the subways are clean and the stores are clean and the sidewalks are clean and it's really pleasant to be there. You never know that the city used to have piles of garbage littering the streets. Taipei and a number of other Taiwanese cities reduced the amount of trash by changing the way the trash got collected. This is my friend, Erin Newport. She lives in Taipei, where the garbage truck comes five nights a week, evenings, like
美国，历史上一直有一种未被征服、未被触及的无边荒野的感觉。你可以把垃圾扔进荒野，它就会消失，你再也不用担心了。但在台北可不是这样。这是一座大城市，但真的很干净，地铁很干净，商店很干净，人行道也很干净，身处其中非常惬意。你绝不会知道这座城市过去曾有成堆的垃圾散落在街道上。台北和许多其他台湾城市通过改变垃圾收集方式减少了垃圾量。这是我的朋友埃琳·纽波特。她住在台北，那里的垃圾车每周来五天，都是在傍晚，比如
after work. In Erin's neighborhood trucks come twice in the evening, at five and at seven. I don't know if you take out the trash like once a week on one of the days. And Aaron's neighborhood trucks come twice in the evening at 5 and at 7. Aaron has to gather her own garbage and recycling and bring it out to a designated street corner and wait for the big yellow truck to come, with an ear perked for the sound of furilies or a maidens prayer coming down the block. Basically, this is a binless system or a garbage canless system. Your trash goes right from your house to the truck, ideally without ever touching the street.
下班后。在埃琳的社区，垃圾车晚上来两次，分别在五点和七点。我不知道你是不是一周挑一天倒一次垃圾。埃琳的社区垃圾车晚上来两次，分别在五点和七点。埃琳必须自己收集垃圾和回收物，把它带到指定的街角，等待亮黄色的卡车到来，竖起耳朵倾听街区里传来的《致爱丽丝》或《少女的祈祷》的声音。基本上，这是一个没有垃圾桶的系统。你的垃圾直接从家里运到卡车上，理想情况下甚至不会接触到街道。
You just have to bring out your garbage in a special bag. I pay my garbage bill by purchasing these blue Typhoon City garbage bags. These official blue garbage bags say city of Taipei on them, and each is emblazoned with a stamp. I buy them from the convenience store across the street. The official blue garbage bags come in a number of different sizes ranging from three leaders to 120 leaders, so the more garbage you throw away, the more it'll cost you.
你只需要用特殊的袋子把垃圾拿出来。我通过购买这些蓝色的台北市垃圾袋来支付垃圾费。这些官方的蓝色垃圾袋上印着台北市的字样，每个袋子上都有一个印章。我是从街对面的便利店买的。官方的蓝色垃圾袋有多种不同尺寸，从3升到120升不等，所以你扔的垃圾越多，花费就越多。
And although Taipei residents have to pay for their garbage by the bag, recycling and compost are free. You don't need to buy bags for them at all. You can just take out your recycling in non-official plastic bags, and you can generate as much compost and recycling as you'd like. So, residents are incentivized to recycle more and throw out less. I watched Erin sort out all of her recyclables into perfect categories. These are the cans, cans and bottles.
尽管台北居民必须按袋支付垃圾费，但回收和堆肥是免费的。你根本不需要为此买袋子。你可以直接用非官方的塑料袋拿去回收，而且你想产生多少堆肥和回收物都可以。因此，居民被激励去多回收、少扔垃圾。我看着埃琳把她所有的可回收物分门别类。这些是罐头、罐子和瓶子。
So we have a few tea bottles. So when Taipei every yellow garbage truck is followed by a small white recycling truck, which is basically a cart full of different bins. There's a bin for plastic bottles, one for glass bottles, different metals and cans, papers and cardboard, and a compost bucket for raw food waste, and a compost bucket for cooked food waste.
所以我们有一些茶瓶。在台北，每辆黄色垃圾车后面都跟着一辆小白回收车，这基本上是一辆装满不同垃圾桶的手推车。有一个装塑料瓶的垃圾桶，一个装玻璃瓶的，不同的金属和罐头，纸张和纸板，一个装生厨余垃圾的堆肥桶，和一个装熟厨余垃圾的堆肥桶。
Taipei residents have to sort their recycling into all these different categories themselves. Although in the white recycling trucks there are officials and volunteers who can help instruct you about which item goes where. So Erin, her housemates and I got all of her bags of trash and different kinds of recycling sorted out. And then we walked about a block down the street to wait with the rest of her neighbors who were all clutching official blue garbage bags.
台北居民必须自己把可回收物分类到所有这些不同的类别中。不过在白色回收车上会有官员和志愿者指导你什么东西该去哪里。所以埃琳、她的室友和我把她所有的垃圾袋和各种可回收物都分类好了。然后我们步行了一个街区，和手里紧紧攥着官方蓝色垃圾袋的其他邻居们一起等待。
I'm sorry to a lot of people gathered here today. And say this is maybe larger than your average crew. Then the moment we were waiting for. Yeah! Yes! There was this mad dash of people swarming to the school bus yellow garbage truck and the white recycling truck. Okay, this one, yeah, people are tossing it in. Swithly tossing their separate recyclables
我很抱歉今天聚集了这么多人。这可能比你的平均规模要大。然后是我们一直在等待的时刻。耶！是的！人们疯狂地冲向校车黄色的垃圾车和白色的回收车。好的，这个，是的，人们把它扔进去。迅速地把各自的可回收物
and the bins, tossing their blue bags and the garbage truck and running away. It was madness, like extremely well organized madness. That was so chaotic. In this system for all its chaos has been working. Taipei City used to produce 3,296 tons of trash a day. Today, the city produces about 1,000 tons a day. That is, according to Chen Wichu, one of 65 officials who supervised the garbage trucks and their routes.
扔进垃圾桶，把蓝色的袋子扔进垃圾车然后跑开。这太疯狂了，就像极其井井有条的疯狂。太混乱了。这个系统尽管混乱，但一直在发挥作用。台北市过去每天产生3296吨垃圾。如今，该市每天产生约1000吨垃圾。这是根据陈维初（音译）的说法，他是监督垃圾车及其路线的65名官员之一。
I met him at a garbage pickup site where Jasmine Wong acted as interpreter. Every week this is Mr. Chen. Hi. And he's super riser. Yes, we all had him. In his district, Chen oversees 20 garbage truck routes. And all those trucks have to make sure that citizens are sorting properly.
我在一个垃圾收集点遇到了他，黄（音译）博士担任口译。每周，这是陈先生。嗨。他是主管。是的，我们都有他。在他的辖区内，陈负责20条垃圾车路线。所有这些卡车都必须确保市民正确分类。
If they find garbage in the recycling bag, the people here will tell them that you cannot do that one more time, otherwise you will get ticket. And how much is the ticket? 200 US dollars. But that's the maximum. And you might think this is such a drag. There must be some people who buck the system by tossing their trash into public trash cans. Well, there are hardly any public trash cans in Taipei.
如果在回收袋里发现垃圾，这里的人会告诉你不准那样做，否则你会收到罚单。罚单是多少钱？200美元。但那是最高金额。你可能会觉得这太麻烦了。肯定有些人把垃圾扔进公共垃圾桶来对抗这个系统。好吧，台北几乎没有什么公共垃圾桶。
They're only in train stations or at bus stops. And those are little, they come up just below your knees. So in Taipei, for the most part, if you eat a candy or buy a coffee, you just take your empty coffee cup or your candy wrapper, put it in your pocket and bring it home. It's your trash that you put in your blue bag and bring out to the truck yourself. It's hard to imagine a system like this working here in the US. Every city here has a different method of trash pickup. But across the board, the uniting factor is that our American trash pickup system strive
它们只在火车站或公交车站才有。而且那些都很小，只到你的膝盖下方。所以在台北，大多数情况下，如果你吃一块糖或买一杯咖啡，你只需要把空咖啡杯或糖果包装纸放进口袋，然后带回家。这是你的垃圾，你把它放在蓝色袋子里自己拿到卡车上。很难想象这样的系统能在这里（美国）行之有效。这里的每个城市都有不同的垃圾收集方法。但总的来说，共同的因素是我们的美国垃圾收集系统力求
to be invisible. The trucks make great efforts to come when we're working, or sleeping, or trying to sleep, keeping out of the way of traffic and not disturbing the flow of the city. We take our trash and recycling out to bins or down a shoot or to a dumpster, and it's gone. We don't have to think about it. According to the EPA, Americans recycle and compost about 34% of their trash, which is less than most rich countries. But some American cities do a lot better. San Francisco has probably the most forward recycling program in North America.
做到隐形。卡车付出巨大努力在我们工作、睡觉或试图睡觉的时候来，避开交通，不打扰城市的运行。我们把垃圾和回收物拿出来放到垃圾桶、滑道或垃圾箱里，然后它们就消失了。我们不用去想它。根据美国环保署的数据，美国人回收和堆肥了大约34%的垃圾，这比大多数富裕国家都要少。但一些美国城市做得好得多。旧金山可能拥有北美最具前瞻性的回收计划。
This is Robert Reed. He's the representative of Recology, the company that takes care of San Francisco's waste recycling and compost. Unlike Taipei, which has a public trash pickup system, many waste pickup services in the US are private companies, and we are the customers. That's how it works with Recology, which means they've got to keep their customers happy. Our number one focus is to provide superior customer service. And our next focus is to do as much recycling as possible and to make recycling easy and convenient for customers. Recology has set up similar incentives to the system in Taipei, where trash
这是罗伯特·里德。他是负责旧金山废物回收和堆肥的公司Recology的代表。与拥有公共垃圾收集系统的台北不同，美国的许多垃圾收集服务都是私营公司，而我们是客户。Recology就是这样运作的，这意味着他们必须让客户满意。我们的首要重点是提供卓越的客户服务。我们的下一个重点是尽可能多地回收利用，并使客户回收利用变得简单方便。Recology建立类似于台北系统的激励机制，在那里垃圾
pickup is way more expensive than recycling or compost pickup. For example, in San Francisco, recycling and compost cost about $2 a month per bin. Trash is about $26 a month per bin. But above all, ecology system is meant to be simple and stress-free. It has to be if you want people to keep paying for your service. People have a lot of demands in their lives, we understand that. You know, recycling might not be the very first thing. They got to make their boss happy, they got to pay their mortgage. Garbage and recycling and composting might not always be at the top of the list. We understand that.
收集的费用比回收或堆肥收集贵得多。例如，在旧金山，回收和堆肥每个垃圾桶每月花费约2美元。垃圾每个垃圾桶每月约26美元。但最重要的是，Recology的系统旨在简单且无压力。如果你想让人们继续为你付服务费，它就必须如此。人们在生活中有很多需求，我们理解这一点。你知道，回收可能不是第一件要做的事。他们得让老板高兴，他们得付房贷。垃圾、回收和堆肥可能并不总是在清单的最前面。我们理解这一点。
Basically instead of putting the onus on the citizens to separate the different kinds of compost and recycling for themselves, Recology does the brunt of the work, sorting the different kinds of compost and recycling for themselves. Recology does the brunt of the work, sorting, so we don't have to. San Francisco, like a lot of other American cities that collect recycling, uses one catch all recycling bin. So you throw your cans, your bottles, your cardboard, all in the same place. And then all those different materials end up in a facility like recycle central. So this is recycle central, this is the large recycling plant on Pier 96,
基本上，Recology没有把分离不同种类堆肥和回收物的责任强加给市民，而是承担了大部分工作，自己对不同种类的堆肥和回收物进行分类，这样我们就不用做了。像许多其他收集回收物的美国城市一样，旧金山使用一个全能的回收箱。所以你把罐子、瓶子、纸板都扔在同一个地方。然后所有这些不同的材料最终都会到达像中央回收厂这样的设施。所以这是中央回收厂，这是位于96号码头的大型回收厂，
where we sort all the materials from the blue bin, the bottles, the cans, the paper. We're going to go inside now. The facility is massive and it's where ecology processes most of San Francisco's recycling. You can see this great big pile of recycling. This is from this morning, this is from one day and we're going to get this sorted out because we got another big pile coming in tomorrow so we do 600 tons a day here. That 600 ton pile will wind its way up a huge surreal web of conveyor belts, where some of the 173 people on staff will separate the recyclables into 16 categories of materials,
我们在那里对蓝色垃圾箱里的所有材料进行分类，包括瓶子、罐头、纸张。我们现在要进去了。这个设施非常巨大，是Recology处理旧金山大部分回收物的地方。你可以看到这大堆回收物。这是从今天早上开始的，这是一天产生的，我们要把这些分类好，因为明天还有一大堆要运进来，所以我们这里一天处理600吨。这600吨的堆料将沿着一条巨大的、超现实的传送带蜿蜒而上，173名员工中的一部分人将把可回收物分成16种材料，
with the help of some modern recycling equipment. So we've got magnets and we have fish ladders that separate bottles and cans from paper. They're on an angle and they temporarily suspend gravity. To make sure everything gets precisely sorted, there's some real state-of-the-art technology, like this apparatus that separates clear plastic from color plastic with optic sensors. Right here, the scanner is looking at the materials as they come by and when it sees a clear plastic, like a clear plastic water bottle, it hits it with a puff of air and you can hear
在一些现代回收设备的帮助下。所以我们有磁铁，我们有鱼梯，把瓶子和罐头从纸张中分离出来。它们是有角度的，并且暂时消除了重力。为了确保每样东西都能精确分类，有一些真正最先进的技术，比如这个用光学传感器将透明塑料与有色塑料分离的装置。就在这里，扫描仪在材料通过时观察它们，当它看到透明塑料（如透明塑料水瓶）时，它会用一股气流击中它，你可以听到
it. It's expensive, it costs $3 million for this machine and it came from the Netherlands. So this system, with all its worrying twirling conveyors and magnets and machinery and 173 employees, it's dazzling and it makes less trash by doing more recycling. And recycling creates 10 times more jobs than landfilling or incineration. Of course, it also takes all the direct sorting out of the hands of the people who actually create the waste and charges them for the service instead. As a result, recycling in the US can be expensive.
声音。这很贵，这台机器耗资300万美元，来自荷兰。因此，这个系统拥有所有这些旋转的传送带、磁铁、机械装置和173名员工，令人眼花缭乱，它通过更多地回收利用来产生更少的垃圾。而且回收创造的就业机会比填埋或焚烧多10倍。当然，这也把直接分类的工作从实际产生垃圾的人手中剥夺了，转而为这项服务向他们收费。因此，在美国回收利用可能会很昂贵。
I guess that's part of the problem, like to the extent that there's pushback in recycling, which I've seen some of in the United States now, it's often about the cost of it, and that's very costly. And that's true if you're using the single-stream processes function, and it's less true if the household does the separating. That's Professor Mary Alice Hadadagin. true if you're using the single-stream processes function and it's less true if the household does the separating. That's Professor Mary Alice Hadad again. If your community wants to recycle, all that stuff needs to be separated and sorted, somehow.
我想这也是问题的一部分，比如在美国现在看到的一些对回收利用的阻力，通常是关于成本的，而且成本很高。如果你使用的是单流处理功能，情况确实如此，但如果是家庭自己进行分类，情况就没那么严重了。这是玛丽·爱丽丝·哈达德教授。如果你的社区想要回收利用，所有这些东西都需要以某种方式被分离和分类。
Whether you use a $3 million machine from the Netherlands or compel an entire sweet potato-shaped island of people to stand on the corner at night. The Taipei system is cheap and efficient because the city has conscripted their citizens as workers, and it's been successful. Taipei is a great example of a big, major global metropolitan area that did not have a good garbage collection system not that long ago and they have completely transformed and it could be an example for us all. Which is not to say we should necessarily copy Taipei's system.
无论你是使用来自荷兰的300万美元的机器，还是强迫一个红薯形状的小岛上的人们晚上站在街角。台北的系统既便宜又高效，因为该市将市民征召为工人，而且它取得了成功。台北是一个很好的大都市例子，在不久前还没有一个好的垃圾收集系统，而他们已经完全转型，这可以成为我们所有人的榜样。这并不是说我们应该完全照搬台北的系统。
What's worked for them might not work for the US. But consider the American garbage truck creeping around at dawn or during work hours, trying to be as inconspicuous as possible, trying to keep trash out of sight and out of mind. You don't really pay attention to it, but everyone should pay a lot of attention. If we had to watch our garbage pile up in our homes without taking it out to the bin and had to set aside time in our days to catch the garbage and recycling trucks coming down the street. I bet we'd produce less junk. But I also think if I had to hear this song twice a night five days a week, I would murder everybody. 99% Invisible was produced as weak by Avery Troubleman, with Katie Mingle, Sam Green
对他们有效的方法可能对美国无效。但想想美国垃圾车在黎明或工作时间悄悄爬行，试图尽可能不引人注目，试图让垃圾眼不见心不烦。你其实并没有注意到它，但每个人都应该多多关注。如果我们不得不看着垃圾在家里堆积而不把它拿出去放到垃圾箱里，并且不得不留出时间来赶上街上驶来的垃圾和回收车。我敢说我们会产生更少的垃圾。但我也觉得如果我一周五天、一天两次听到这首歌，我会杀所有人。99% Invisible 本周由埃弗里·特鲁布尔曼制作，凯蒂·明格、萨姆·格林
Span, Delaney Hall, Kurt Coles, Dead, Sheree, Views, Seth, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Helen Sang, Erin Newport, Ethan Young, Sam Langton, and Jasmine Wong. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced under the offices of Arxine, in architecture and interiors firm in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. You can follow us all on Twitter and Instagram. We have a very good Tumblr that Avery takes care of, but the best way to explore the 99%
斯潘、德兰尼·霍尔、库尔特·科尔斯·达德、谢里·维斯、塞思以及我罗曼·马斯共同制作。本周特别鸣谢海伦·桑、埃琳·纽波特、伊桑·杨、萨姆·兰顿和黄。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在美丽加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的建筑和室内设计公司 Arxine 的赞助下制作。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并关注这个节目。你可以在 Twitter 和 Instagram 上关注我们。我们有一个埃弗里负责的很好的 Tumblr，但探索 99%
invisible activity that shapes the design of our world is to do a deep dive on our website. It's 99pi.org. The valuable activity that shapes the design of our world is to do a deep dive on our website. It's 99pi.org. Radio TIPI from P-R-X. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
塑造我们世界设计的不可见活动的最好方法是对我们的网站进行深入了解。网址是 99pi.org。塑造我们世界设计的宝贵活动是对我们的网站进行深入了解。网址是 99pi.org。来自 P-R-X 的 Radio TIPI。这集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。